[Music]
my name's Ben Allen I'm a professor of
theoretical physics at the University of
Cambridge and I am I used to work at
CERN and I still go out and work there a
lot so I work on their data and I work
on mathematical models of particle
physics and how and forces and the early
universe and my area of work is really
between the data and theory trying to
inform one by the other and sort of bad
things back and forwards and up until
last year
I spent all my career work working on
the supersymmetry theory which is a
theory of particle physics and but we
thought that the Large Hadron Collider
experiment at CERN was going to produce
particles predicted new particles
predicted by the supersymmetry theory
and it hasn't like this this hope hasn't
panned out so I've kind of shifted what
what I'm working on
but the supersymmetry theory was
beautiful
to work on for a while it was it had
very lofty ideals it it was oh it was a
bridge to theories of everything theory
like mathematical theories of all
particles and forces which tried to
explain everything about our universe so
you know dark matter how forces work
what what we're made of you know what
light is everything but you the problem
with them was you had to make quite a
lot of assumptions to to predict just a
few things that you could measure and
test in an experiment and then we looked
in the experiment and they weren't there
so yeah so I had to rethink last year
and now I'm working in a different mode
I'm looking at the data and looking for
glitches and so we predict with the
standard model of particle physics
that's the current knowledge that we
have we predict how the data should look
from the collisions between two protons
that
at CERN at high energies and we look for
cases where the the model disagrees the
prediction disagrees with what's what
scene and then for that that for me is
an opportunity so then we we jump on
that and try and explain it but explain
it in a very simple way we kind of just
bung in an extra force or an extra
particle that would explain the what
scene and then we do some proper
phenomenology so we try and suggest
other ways in which it may be tested we
first of all check that it's consistent
with all other data and then suggest
other ways you can save the data to look
for these new particles or forces and
then you know go one step further in the
theoretical direction so this is more we
call it bottom-up science working from
the data and where you've got really
solid foundation and you think you know
what's going on and then making
hypotheses away from that so I'm
enjoying this new way of working it's
certainly quite different to the
previous way where you try and solve
everything and make loads of assumptions
that's what that we called top-down you
know it's like you start from pure
thought thoughts and then try and get to
your experimental observations but for
me anyway that that that approach hasn't
panned out so you know I'm trying a new
approach and it's and it's a lot of fun
so this change in starting from a data
and rather than theory does this mean
that you've sort of given up hope of
finding supersymmetrical particle okay
so if the works still focused on
supersymmetry are you that's just a
belief you have but you can't like no I
okay so looking at my own work at the
moment the way the way I answer this
question is the way for me to make
progress right now is not to work on
supersymmetry and the reason is because
we know from the data that the Large
Hadron Collider has seen already that in
the next few years there's not going to
be a big discovery of secret
supersymmetric particles otherwise we
would have seen small fluctuations and
the data already so
the next years for me that's not where
the discovery is going to be so I'm
looking elsewhere but still you know you
can't help in your heart of hearts
believe in this beautiful theory which
explains a really important fact that we
otherwise don't understand
and that fact is why is the Higgs boson
so light so if you do calculations on
Higgs bosons and they're they're
affected by quantum fluctuations the
littles the sieving of space-time in
terms of other particles and they're
they're special in that they feel those
fluctuations extremely sensitively and
if you do back-of-the-envelope
calculations those fluctuations should
increase its mass by something like a
billion billion times more than it then
it's been measured to be so this this is
a puzzle that we don't understand with
our current theory it's not explained
why is the Higgs boson so light and how
is it able to stay so light with these
quantum fluctuations supersymmetry
explains this it doesn't mean it's the
only that doesn't mean it's the only
explanation but the other ones don't
work or you know we haven't really found
a decent of the one so that's why we
were so keen on on it and why we thought
we might be able to find supersymmetric
particles as a signal that the theory
was right at the Large Hadron Collider
so you know if in I don't know five or
ten years time some signals start
appearing from the data of course I'm
going to jump back right back on it
right but for the moment I think in
terms of progress it's it's more
fruitful for me personally to you to
look elsewhere and why do you think
there is this pulses of the grand theory
of everything why is this gonna focus in
particle physics rather than starting
from the data I well I mean the truth
you know if I'm honest the truth is that
actually lots of different approaches
are taken by everyone and it's a
question of balance of how much you you
wait one thing against another and
people work in different ways and so on
but then the grand unified theories are
ambitious I mean if you if you could
explain everything in one
fells sweep everything you know not
everything it's not gonna dis it's not
gonna explain how you fall in love for
instance right for everything about
particle physics and perhaps even the
early universe that's a very tempting
seductive idea right so that's partly it
but also just theoretical progress was
made
I mean people didn't realize these grand
unified theories could exist in the 60s
1960s and then later on you know that
they sort of popped out of the theory
and so it was a theoretical playground
where potentially you could explain
everything all of a sudden and so
there's a lot of activity on it but
looked for experimental signatures that
they were correct one of the main ones
actually with grand unified theories was
the protons you know the particles
inside of atoms in the nuclear and the
center they should decay and they set up
this bonkers experiment in a mountain in
Japan in the kameoka mountain where it's
they basically hollowed it out and
filled it with water and put all of
these detectors around the outside that
measure light and they looked for
protons decaying within this within the
water basically so you've got a lot of
water and so you know if one of the
protons decays you can see it so you can
get very strong bounds on its own
protons lifetime because there's so many
protons in this in this water and the
current bound on the lifetime is like
roughly it's got to be longer than 10 to
the 32 years that's much longer than the
age of the universe so it's it's
challenging the grand unified theories
and pushing them and you know when you
when you don't have a good experimental
signal that the theories right I mean
you don't know where to go with it you
can do lots of theoretical work but in
the end you don't really know whether
your theory is right or not and you've
written that particle physics is in
crisis is it to do with this focus on
theory so I don't really
I don't think that's the big crisis I
think there's a crisis in terms of the
higgs-boson in this hierarchy problem
and the fact that supersymmetry doesn't
seem to be right and we don't understand
why the Higgs boson so light I think in
theoretical particle physics has a
problem with that and we don't
understand it and it may mean that we
need to somehow shift paradigm maybe
there's something going on with the
Higgs mechanism you know the mechanism
by which all the particles get their
mass subatomic particles get their mass
yeah but so it may just be that there's
a puzzle we needed a shift of
perspective to really understand that
but yeah they may just be that but I
don't I mean I don't think that the
whole subject is in crisis because we've
been to theoretically driven because
experiments are going on and there are
people who work in various ways within
that last century actually it was mainly
well we had iron stein who and Dirac
they were the big top-down theoretical
physicists you know inventing things
from pure pure thought and mathematics
and they had some very big impressive
successes with that but most of the
other progress from my point of view in
particle physics was either bottom-up or
it came more from a batting back and
forwards and interplay between theory
and data and so all of that continues
that there at the same time it's more
that I've just changed the way I'm
working and hope to make more progress
this this new way again and now they're
equivalent big names of physicists who
use sort of bottom-up bottom-up process
that you've been inspired by in your own
work like comparable to Einstein who is
famous for top dollar 30 I think the
top-down theorists I mean they're very
clever people they get there they get
more of the big names but there are
certainly some goods you might call them
phenomenologist people who wore at work
bottom bottom up bo Kane for instance
and some other physicists you probably
won't won't have heard of as much
and some some of the top-down people
also did bottom-up I mean if you're
sensible you use everything you know
available to you I guess yeah and the
work you're doing at CERN con like in
regards to the Higgs boson what sort of
data are you using there in more detail
yeah so at CERN that protons are
collided at extremely high energies it's
fourteen thousand billion electron volts
worth of energy in the beam about 13
actually 13,000 and so they what you do
is you put a detector around the point
where you cross the counter-rotating
beams so these act like 3d 3d cameras
and what comes out is a spray of a
thousand fiery fragments and so what
you're doing is detective work to kind
of go back in time look at each
collision and try and work out what was
going on right at the center and which
particles existed for a fleeting 99
fraction of a second so that's how the
Higgs boson was discovered actually the
Discovery Channel was when they decayed
into two particles of highly energetic
light so you get two photons going more
or less back-to-back with particular
energy so their energies add up to the
mass of the Higgs boson okay so it's
that through Einstein's equation e
equals mc-squared you're turning the
energy of the beams into the mass of the
Higgs boson which then and goes into the
energy of the light so that's so you do
various bits of detective work so that
the Higgs a particle which is very much
like the Standard Model Higgs boson was
discovered but then you want to check
you know does it behave in all the
different ways like it's supposed to
have we really got a whole of the theory
so it's as well as going into two
particles of light the chance of that is
like one in 500 it just happens that it
is easy to spot those ones but it also
decays in other ways and so you check to
see if the frequencies all
agree with the theory and so far they
pretty much look like the standard model
as has got it bang-on so we've got this
dichotomy where the standard model is
telling us that the experimental
signatures of the Higgs boson all agree
with its predictions but then we use the
theory to set to try and estimate the
mass of the Higgs boson and you get it
right but I strong by some huge factor
so it's an interesting situation to be
in
yeah and that was the thing if we had
supersymmetry then we'd understand it
all and but we don't and what would the
ramifications be of understanding why
the higgs boson is so light why is that
sort of a barrier at the moment in
theoretical physics well the the big
rate I mean we want to understand how
particles act we have this so the
standard model of particle physics is a
list of all the particles that have been
discovered experimentally including the
forces and but it's a mathematical
quantum field theory it's a mathematical
framework that tells you how they act it
can predict precisely for you what the
frequencies are various things happening
are when you do these collisions and if
you just use that theory it's it's
successful in nearly always apart from
this one way of predicting their higgs
mass so it's like a [ __ ] in the armor
of this whole machinery and of course
chinks in the armor if you can find out
what's why it's gone wrong then you go
through to the next stage you make a big
discovery and we just find out more
about the universe so this is pure blue
skies research we just want to find out
about the universe and the way it works
it's not particularly application driven
you know you're doing a lot of turning
mass into energy and vice versa so there
may be some hopes in the future for
energy generation but this is like way
off I mean at the moment we're just
trying to find what's going on and
there's also work on proton therapy
and this basically accelerating protons
using much you know very similar
techniques that they use its own and so
this Rd going on to onto that and it can
be good for various deep type kinds of
tumors and so on for treating those
things how does that work
well you you basically fire the proton
beam into the body and it dumps all the
energy at a certain depth so when you've
got very deep tumors it can be very
damaging to the chimp tumor but not so
damaging on the outside so it first
certain kinds of cancer it's it's
indicated whereas other treatments you
know it might damage the rest of the
body too much so it can be can be more
localized so in certain cases it's it's
very useful and that there are there are
proton therapy treatment centers there's
no one in the UK and there's another one
being built in yeah so it has all these
spin-offs you know because it's you're
pushing technology further than it's
been before and of course there are uses
for it and so sounds engaging with
medical physics and all sorts of things
so for example cat scans the if you if
you get cat scans these days the modern
version of that was invented by the
medical physics team in in CERN where it
takes x-rays and you know and get builds
up a 3d picture and at the same time so
yeah there's there's also some good
stuff kind of coming out of it it's
directly relevant to society and are you
hopeful that you'll work out why the
Higgs boson is so light yeah always
hopeful never yeah yeah I've got no good
ideas at the moment and but we will see
at the moment actually I'm looking at
other data there are these particles
called bottom nezam in essence okay and
they're decaying with the wrong
frequencies so I think we've I think
there's a glitch in the data so that's
an opportunity for me so we think there
might be a new force whose which is
breaking up these bottom resins with the
wrong frequencies
and so yeah we're proposing ways of
testing that theory at the moment so
this is this bottom-up way of working
just found a glitch propose something
which doesn't necessarily explain
anything else but just to explain this
data but then now we're starting to ask
well what does that mean you know if it
there really is this new force what else
can it explain and so we're starting to
build a theoretical framework around it
yeah it's a lot of fun if I think yeah
it's exciting hopefully you'll have next
time you come to this festival you hear
it might take a few years
one last question we are artists an
ideas festival
I wondered if there's any films or music
there's like inspired your own work
growing up or has an influence on you
well you know like many of my colleagues
I was a science-fiction fan when I grew
up so I used to read a lot of Isaac
Asimov and I don't know I I was always
interested in in astronomy and in
planets and stars when I was a kid so
read loads on that what else it's like
the other way around at the moment my I
draw I do life drawings and so and I go
to a life drawing class straight after
work say I go to this class and I've
always got physics in my head when I'm
when I'm drawing so it's come out in the
drawing so it's like the other way
around for me so I had this I had an
exhibition last year and did this is
called quantum cells and there's lots of
kind of layered images and there's
obvious parallels with quantum physics
and superposition and things like that
so yeah it's like my science has
inspired the art a bit yeah that's
that's been a lot of fun
you should set up like a life drawing
class at CERN I've done I did yeah I
liked during classes then that's a great
idea I see four more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you